how do you keep places that people go
the most
disinfected well this morning we're
getting a closer look at ways to keep
areas clean during the pandemic
specifically at metro police
headquarters where we have hector mejia
live this morning near downtown
with a closer look hector good morning
to you
hey there good morning guys this is
really cool we're inside a training room
here at
metro police headquarters and check out
these cool uniforms
before the city and the sheriff's
departments merged
back in the 70s it's pretty cool to
watch and joining us live here
we have a whole crew disinfecting uh
different facilities here at the police
department this is
eric co-founder at germ hero all right
so what is that backpack you you have on
what are you guys doing right now it's
like ghostbusters huh it really does
sure so this is called an electrostatic
sprayer
and what this does is it takes this
infection solution that's in the back
here
and it actually electrically charges
those particles and what that does is it
allows us to
effectively spread that solution very
evenly across the surface because
this is a negative service and when we
positively charge the solution
it will go ahead and wrap around so i
can show you a quick demonstration
sounds like it has a lot of science
involved
sure sure does and it's a very effective
way to disinfect quickly so what we can
do is you'll see
it'll actually be a very nice coated
mist and so that's kind of almost like
we're
statically spraying all around here and
so
and it doesn't smell like anything no we
use a very safe and effective different
disinfecting agent
and so it's what hospitals commonly use
in their operating rooms and it's called
hypochlorous acid
so the reason why we're here is we're
highlighting profiling how the company
has donated its services here
not only at this police department but
many others across the country
as well absolutely we work with uh
organizations like toys for tots and we
work with a lot of
national companies as well and providing
the services for free
yes uh well not for free for for
businesses but for other organizations
for that are for a good event or good
cause
we do that for free yes we do how
affordable is it for like let's say
someone at home wants to have the
service done they had maybe a
family member that had kovit and they
want to make sure everything is
disinfected
absolutely and that's what we're here
for very often we get called for covered
responses and our services are actually
very affordable
it's more affordable than an average
cleaning service what's next for you
guys any other partnerships here locally
we did uh get uh reached out to by north
las vegas police department as well
and we're constantly reaching out to
first responders including medical
also elderly facilities we love working
with schools and so we've been reaching
out to a lot of different schools and
trying to help them open back up as well
and here for uh metro police alone it's
about twenty five thousand dollars worth
of services you guys donated
absolutely so we've gone ahead and
donated that twenty five thousand
dollars worth of services
for over a hundred five thousand square
feet so we really wanna be able to help
out and
do what we can eric thank you for your
time and for having us over
we'll be posting all of this information
on our website eightnewsnow.com if you
wanna learn a little bit more
about the services that they provide
reporting live this morning hector mejia
8 news now back to you